while the media incessantly focus on
trump they studiously avoid scrutinizing
joe biden and kamala harris trump vows
to declassify all documents surrounding
russiagate and the political world goes
berserk after trump vows to kill
stimulus talks i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
well then visit expressvpn.com stay
anonymous alrighty so tonight the big
biden
here well harris pence debate and and i
should say that
this debate should take on more
significance than normally a vp debate
would considering that joe biden
is 78 years old he does not look as
though he is all there
and of course mike pence is probably the
best defender of the trump
agenda that the trump administration has
he's a better defender in many cases of
the trump agenda than trump himself
so tonight will be an opportunity for
pence to put front and center the fact
that biden harris would be very scary
for the country it is pretty incredible
truly
that the entire country has completely
ignored the other side of the ticket
it's it's pretty impressive everybody's
focused in on trump
some of that's trump's fault because
trump loves being in the spotlight but
if trump loses if trump loses what is
going to happen to the country
is going to be something quite radical
it could be a significant change
and we all seem to be ignoring this
because all of the focus is on trump
we'll get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that right now things are
pretty volatile you may have noticed
that the stock market
took a dump yesterday after president
trump started tweeting about
relief talks and all of this well the
stock market's been up and down
like a yo-yo it may not in fact be
the best place to put your money in the
short term in fact if you're going to
have some money in the stock market
which i do i have lots of money in the
stock market you want to diversify and
have at least a little more of your
money
in something like precious metals you
want to make sure that you are
diversified
into a bunch of different assets so that
when the stock market goes down and
precious metals go up you don't end up
losing
a lot of money and right now again
uncertainty breeds
all sorts of craziness in the stock
market it creates the possibility of
inflation i mean we just blew out the
spending to the tune of seven trillion
dollars
now would be a good time to diversify
into precious metals what do you do to
do that well you hang out with my
friends over at birch gold text ben's
47-47-47
one of the great people at birch gold
will then walk you through your
conversion of your eligible ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira where the
physical metal not etfs will be stored
securely birch gold they're my dudes
they have an a plus rating with the
better business bureau and countless
five-star reviews
talk to them they are extremely
knowledgeable they can help you preserve
your savings text ben 247 4747 open a
precious metals ira today again
text ben to 47 47 47 text ben 247
47 47. so as i said yesterday with
regard to this election
the basic state of the election is thus
if the focus is on trump when people
walk
into the ballot box then trump is going
to lose if the focus is on joe biden and
kamal harris then joe biden and kamal
harris are going to lose
trump has a pathological inability to
remove himself from the spotlight he
loves the spotlight he loves being in
the center of the spotlight
and that means that he has put himself
at a severe disadvantage well tonight is
an opportunity for mike pence
who really does not love the spotlight
in the same way as trump to put the
biden harris agenda front and center
and this is going to need to happen
because the reality is again
that right now all focus is on trump and
that has allowed all of us
and i mean like most of the american
people to simply ignore what is
happening on the other side of the aisle
a democratic party that has moved in a
radical direction
i know that we are pretending that the
squad is basically a thing of the past
but what actually happened is that
bernie sanders agenda the squad's agenda
they've been laundered into the joe
biden agenda
bernie sanders says it himself he says
the joe biden agenda is the most radical
agenda since fdr
and the squad is going to be running
things when it comes to things like the
green new deal aoc is an advisor on the
biden campaign with regard to
the green new deal joe biden is not
going to be a bulwark against radicalism
there have been no indicators he's going
to be a bulwark against radicalism he
won't even answer basic questions
like whether he is in favor of killing
the filibuster and packing the supreme
court
and many of the senate candidates for
the democrats are saying the same thing
they're just refusing to answer
questions they understand that as long
as there's this black hole
at the center of american politics
sucking up all the attention they can
just
sit there on the outskirts of american
politics and point to trump and never
have to answer to have questions
mark kelly who's running a a winning
race right now against martha mcsally in
arizona
he refused to answer a question the
other night in debate with mcsally on
whether he is in favor of the filibuster
wouldn't that be something you'd want to
know if you're voting for a senator
whether they actually wish to end
minority rights
completely in the senate wouldn't that
be something that you would want to know
apparently he doesn't think he has to
answer and the media are not going to
press the democrats on this stuff
so understand that if trump loses
radical things are going to happen
it's going to be a victory for a bunch
of people who you probably don't want to
see win
it's going to be a victory for the
radicals in the democratic party
it is going to be a victory for a media
that has
turned all of its guns on trump now as
i've said trump
has cast himself many self-inflicted
wounds
but the media have been so
overwhelmingly anti-trump i mean it is
far more than it was with bush it was
bad with bush it is way worse with trump
they hate trump with every fiber of
their being over 90 of all media
coverage of trump since his inauguration
has been negative
it's a victory for a media that is
driving the american political narrative
it's a victory for folks inside the
bureaucracy of the government
who think that they ought to control the
the power of american government not the
legislature not the states it all ought
to be done at the federal level
it's a victory for all the forces in
america that were temporarily checked by
trump's election
in the first place and that's why this
election actually matters an awful lot
it's one of the reasons why
i've been critical of trump's behavior
over the last couple of weeks because if
you would like to see trump win
then he needs to change his behavior
something certainly needs to change and
the american people need to be forcibly
reminded
force fully reminded rather they need to
be forcefully reminded
of exactly what is going to happen if
trump loses what's going to be
right what comes next because no one's
thinking beyond the next 10 seconds
people are just thinking do i like trump
do i not like trump
no one is thinking medium term let alone
long term
and right now the polls are reflecting
this okay the polls show that this race
seems to have broken
wide open nationally according to the
real clear politics poll average
joe biden is now leading in that real
clear politics poll average by nine
points
the last several polls and this is this
is the last four polls in the real clear
politics poll average have biden up
respectively
16 10 8 and 10. okay those are those are
devastatingly large numbers
hillary clinton even after the access
hollywood tape never led by more than
about seven points
so these are big numbers for joe biden
and people should recognize that those
are numbers for joe biden not just
against trump
you actively have to cast your vote not
just against trump but in favor
of a candidate who is enthralled to the
radical left while he pretends that he's
actually a bulwark against the radical
left what's more
if trump were to lose big right not just
lose but lose big he could take the
senate with him
and this is an arena where if you're a
voter you really should consider the
consequences of your actions
an abide in presidency with the
republican senate looks very different
than a biden's abide in presidency with
a democratic senate
and right now if there were no tossups
in the real clear politics poll average
democrats would control the senate
they'd have 51 votes in the senate
right now there are a bunch of races
that are very very close north carolina
is becoming closer and closer
georgia with sonny perdue i think purdue
wins that race
but maine is a very close race with
susan collins up for re-election
in iowa joni ernst is up for re-election
and her opponent
a person named greenfield is apparently
winning in the real clear politics poll
average by five
montana is very close steve daines who's
a republican probably will hold that
seat but it is a close election mark
kelly
is winning in fairly large numbers in
arizona over martha mcsally
south carolina has been moved recently
by cook political
from a lean r to a toss-up which is
insane lindsey graham
won his last re-election campaign by 14
points
14 points now he's in a toss-up race in
south carolina
colorado is already leaning against cory
gardner
and republicans need to hold at least
five seats in order for them to
maintain the majority in the senate
because remember if kamala harris
becomes vice president she would be the
tiebreaker
in the senate in case of a 50-50 tie in
the senate
right now it doesn't look like
republicans are gonna hold those five
seats in fact it looks like republicans
of the eight seats that are that are
really contested it looks like
republicans could easily lose five of
those seats
so that's why the margin of victory for
for trump or margin of loss that that
margin is actually going to matter
an awful lot and the emboldening of all
the forces in american life
that are making american life
significantly worse will grow worse
not better with trump losing i know that
people have personal problems with trump
i i share many of the concerns about
trump's personality
but if you're talking about the deep
abiding problems in american life
they're far worse than trump's
personality foibles and flaws and his
stupid tweeting
okay if we're talking about serious
problems in america problems that are
going to be exacerbated over the course
of time
the glorification of a media that has
gone completely left partisan while
claiming to be objective
the justification of that media the
strengthening of that media apparatus
the strengthening of the radical left
wing of the democratic party under the
auspices
of joe biden's moderation i mean the man
is a facade at this point and we all
know that he is a facade he's a potemkin
village of a candidate
the the bureaucracy that has kicked back
against trump
in harsh measures we'll see all those
forces will be strengthened
and all those forces are in fact rather
anti-democratic they are not in favor of
your individual rights
they are not forces who are in favor of
truth or in favor of objectivity
there is another side to this election
we've all neglected it for too long and
it's time to cast a light
on that here's here's a perfect example
okay so
right now the senate majority may rest
on this case this this election in north
carolina so in north carolina
tom tillis who is a solid republican is
running for re-election
against cal cunningham who's a former
state senator a democrat
well kel cunningham has started to drop
a little bit of the polls now that now
it's basically straight up
even one of the reasons that it is
straight up even is because
cal cunningham has admitted to now
sending romantic texts to a woman who is
not his wife
he said in a statement to cnn i've hurt
my family disappointed my friends i'm
deeply sorry the first step in repairing
those relationships is taking complete
responsibility which i do
i ask that my family's privacy be
respected in this personal
matter he backed out of a town hall
scheduled for monday night the messages
are
this is cnn's coverage right this is
when i say that you are that you are
you know being treated to the worst of
media bias is chris
chaliza over at cnn the messages are far
from tawdy they read like 1950s letters
but the very fact that they exist does
throw a major x-factor into the senate
race
okay well actually it turns out that now
the news seems to be breaking
that cal cunningham was having romantic
assignations
with this particular person so they
weren't 1950s texts actually
there's an actual sex scandal that has
been going on
in this particular race there were new
texts
that were revealed in a new report from
the associated press arlene
guzman todd a woman from california
confirmed that she and cunningham had
been intimate in july so it turns out it
wasn't just a texting scandal or a
sexting scandal
and additional text messages between
guzman todd and a third unidentified
individual further described the details
of their relationship
the ap report is the first corroboration
of a physical consensual relationship
between cunningham
and guzman todd those previously
reported they'd exchanged sexually
suggestive text messages but cnn
originally tried to paint this as a
1950s
style romantic language via text
so yes well done media this is the same
media again we are strengthening these
folks
and we are strengthening these folks
these are the same media who are now
glorifying katie hill
now you may remember the name katie hill
because she was of course the
representative from california who had
to resign her seat after turns out she
was banging the help
katie hell who is having an affair with
a male
staffer and she was also having an
affair with a female staffer
and she's just at a light now imagine if
she had been a man
imagine that you were a male member of
congress and she were nailing the help
she would have not only been forced to
resign should never come back there
would be no career
for her in the future now katie hill is
having a movie
made about her by hollywood elizabeth
moss is now attached to play former
congresswoman katie hill in an
adaptation of her memoir so she wrote a
memoir about how she was the true victim
of her own inability to control her
loins
and now we are supposed to believe that
she is actually the victim because
hollywood
is going to write an entire story around
her with her as the hero
code black creator michael seitzman who
wrote the feature film north country
will write the screenplay
it comes after the producer blumhouse
television optioned the rights to she
will rise becoming a warrior in the
battle for true equality which was
published earlier this summer
the book tells of hill's experience as a
young woman with no prior political
experience whose charm and common sense
went over the people in her district and
thruster into the halls of power in
washington
while her brash confidence won her
powerful allies and infuriated her
enemies it was privately concealing a
cycle of domestic abuse she was trapped
in at home
infamously culminating in the release of
intimate photos and the revelation of
her own
admitted personal mistakes that would
eventually result in her stunning
fall from grace hill will executive
produce the movie
along with moss and lindsey mcmanus
imagine they got a republican
male congress person banging the help
you think they get a movie deal where
they get to executive produce their own
story about how they were truly a victim
of right-wing predation what do you
think katie hill said
i wrote she will rise to try and take
back my story from those who have
exploited and twisted it
i also wanted to shine a light on the
stories of women whose resilience and
bravery gave me strength when i needed
it most
okay well hilariously enough the former
staff of katie hill
hijacked her twitter account last night
right they logged into her twitter
account because it turns
it turns out that she was not smart
enough not only not to nail the help but
also
to prevent the help from hacking her
twitter account without two-factor
identification turn on the two-factor
identification
lady so they they hijacked her twitter
account
and here's what they wrote on her
twitter account katie's former staff
here
disappointed in so many folks including
elizabeth moth elizabeth moss blumhouse
and michael seitzman regarding today's
announcement
katie took advantage of her subordinates
she caused immense harm to the people
who worked for her many of whom were
young women
just beginning their careers in politics
katie hill can be both a victim and a
perpetrator and staff can experience
severe consequences for speaking out
against their powerful bosses
but this is your media right this is
your hollywood apparatus these are the
people who create a tsunami
of misinformation and if biden wins
then that point of view has been
vindicated this media apparatus this
hollywood
that has all been vindicated so the goal
right now
politically speaking of the biden
campaign is to declare the campaign over
the campaign's over
right we still have a month to go
doesn't matter campaign is dead
yesterday joe biden said that if trump
has coveted
by the time of the debate then we still
shouldn't debate okay well first of all
theoretically he could take precautions
second of all by the time they have the
debate that's going to be october 15th
is the next debate that is eight days
away
and trump according to his doctors is
already asymptomatic he's already
post-symptomatic rather
so assuming no actual assuming no actual
change in his health status
he's going to be perfectly capable of
debate here is biden trying to set the
predicate for saying there won't be any
more debates
i don't know what uh exactly what the
rules are gonna be
and i'm not sure that uh
what president trump is all about now i
don't know
what his status is i'm looking forward
to being able to debate him
but i just hope all the protocols are
followed was necessary at the time
do you feel safe in the same room as
somebody
well uh i think if he still has covet
we shouldn't have a debate okay so
there it is if you still has covered we
shouldn't have a debate this is already
setting the groundwork
over at the new york times the editorial
board says in-person debates are too
dangerous
we should cancel the in-person debates
they say with the coronavirus continuing
to spread through the white house and
among others close to trump the risk of
infecting debate participants and staff
is unacceptably high the involved media
outlets and the commission on
presidential debates
need to immediately shift the events to
a virtual format which of course
radically changes all of the optics of a
particular
debate and changes it into a zoom
meeting which is not exactly what you
want
from a presidential debate so no shock
here
you know the media are already trying to
declare the election over
they're also trying to declare kamala
harris the preliminary winner of a
debate that has not yet taken place
again these are the same media one of
the trump has campaigned against the
media when he said to chris wallace i'm
campaigning against you and joe biden
what he meant broadly speaking is
correct that he has been campaigning
against both the media and the democrats
and that is a heavy burden for anyone
and it was a heavy burden for bush
mccain
romney it's a particularly heavy burden
for trump because trump has been
absolutely excoriated by the press every
waking moment
since 2015. there's no question about
that and that carries over
for the new york times today wait until
you hear their take on the debate
between pence
and harris tonight and then we'll get to
the actual consequences
of electing somebody like joe biden
which is something americans should have
to stare straight in the face of
considering that that will be the result
of voting against trump in just one
second
let's talk about that first let's talk
about how you can make
doing business easier during these
trying and wild times one thing you
probably don't want to do head on down
to the post office like why would you
want to stand in line at the post office
post office is great but that's not
something you want to do
instead why not just do all of this
stuff from home or from the office with
stamps.com
stems.com makes doing business easier
during these
wild times thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com in recent months
they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office all from their own
computers with stamps.com you can print
postage on demand and avoid going to the
post office
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges here at daily
wire we've been using stamps.com since
2017.
we're not wasting our time stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need
directly to your computer in the comfort
of your home or office whether you're a
small business sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products
or whether you're just working from home
you need to mail some stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with ease i've been
using stamps.com since long before
they're actually a sponsor of the
program and again you get great
discounts five cents off every stamp up
to 62 percent off usps and
ups shipping rates right now my
listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week crowd plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter shapiro again stamps.com enter
shapiro okay so here
is the new york times here is how
they are covering the the harris pence
debate
okay this is pretty impressive for all
ms harris's meticulous work
her team is deeply cognizant of the
unique challenges facing her
as the first black woman ever to win a
place on a presidential ticket okay
first of all there is no unique
challenge
there's only unique benefit seriously
there's only unique benefit
kamala harris has experienced no
challenge in being a black woman in a
position
of high power in american politics not
since she was a d.a
in california the fact is it has only
been an asset to her because if she were
a white lady she would not be on the
ticket right now she would be amy
klobuchar and she'd be off in minnesota
doing zoom sessions
for dnc little crowds
right she would not be a famous person
right now where she's not a black woman
tom lahares should just be like any
other rote democratic politician because
she is not good at this
she's not michelle obama she's not
uniquely talented
because she's actually kind of bad at
this as we're going to explore in just a
second but
again this is new york times media
coverage right there's sydney ember and
lisa lehrer this is their reporting okay
this is not an opinion piece
her team is deeply cognizant of the
unique challenges facing her as the
first black woman ever to win a place on
a presidential ticket
well many democrats view ms harris as
barrier-breaking hero fox news hosts and
conservative media outlets have mounted
racist and sexist assaults on her
reputation painting her as a radical
leftist
well there it is i mean if the new york
times says so how dare how dare
conservative media outlets paint her as
a radical leftist after she embraced
medicare for all
racial reparations and killing the
filibuster
and spent her days during the kavanaugh
hearings attempting to claim
that she had evidence that he was
secretly in league with the russians
now she's not a radical officer you know
only somebody who's racist could say
that kamala harris is on the radical
left only somebody
she by the way she has one of the most
left-wing voting records in the entire
united states senate
and by some measures she's left to
bernie sanders in her voting record but
don't worry it's only crazy
right-wingers
who are who are painting her as a
radical leftist according to your very
objective media
right all of the attacks on her that
paragraph is so
that encapsulates everything that the
media are it really does
right that she faces unique challenges
as a black woman and also if you say
anything bad about kamala harris it's
because you're a racist
so what you're telling me is that her
unique challenge is that
every time somebody says something
accurate about her the media are going
to malign that person
as a bigot that doesn't seem like a
challenge that seems like a benefit
this doesn't seem like she's having a
hard time it sounds like she's having a
really easy time specifically because
she's a black woman
particularly in the media and then who
do they quote in this article the new
york times about kamala harris
hillary clinton there you go they go
back to the last victim hillary clinton
one of the least victimized people in
the history of american politics because
remember
hillary clinton was a non-entity no name
who married the president of the united
states right she was married to bill
clinton that is how she became famous
otherwise she was just
a a another lawyer from yale right she
had a sterling record as a lawyer from
yale and she would be working in
corporate law right now
or she might be you know a state senator
in new york
but now hillary clinton is a nationally
known name because she married the guy
who had become president of the united
states and then on the basis of that
name if her name were hillary rodham she
would not have been a senator from new
york and she certainly would not have
been vice pres
she certainly would not have been
secretary of state or presidential
candidate
but we're going to go back to another
victim of the american system hillary
clinton one of the least victimized
people in the history of american
politics
she said at a fundraiser with harris
last month what mike pence will try to
do is somehow
subtly undercut kamala she has to
modulate her responses because we know
there still is a double standard alive
and well when it comes to women in
politics so the
the the debate has already been settled
according to the media according to the
media the debate between pence and
harris no matter what pence says
it's sexist if he just disagrees with
her that is sexist
if at any point during the debate she
interrupts him that's
stand-up women and roar and if pence
interrupts her that is him
mansplaining remember when trump
if if trump loses the media are the
people who are most emboldened by this
because they have taken down the sitting
president
of the united states despite the fact
that he defeated them
last time all right so as to the actual
debate what is that going to look like
so apparently there was some argument
over whether to use plexiglas barriers
at this debate with harris they will put
up these plexiglass barriers apparently
after the commission on presidential
debates announced plans for kamala
harris
and vice president pence to debate
wednesday while sitting more than a
dozen feet apart and behind plexiglass
dividers to prevent viral transmission
aids depends said they felt the barriers
were unnecessary we don't think it's
needed said mark short there's no
science to support it
the tables are 12 feet apart each
participant is tested it's important for
the american people the debate go
forward if she's more comfortable with
plexiglas
then that's fine the biden campaign was
on board with the precautions senator
harris will be at the debate respecting
the protections the cleveland clinic has
put in place to promote safety
for all concerned said sabrina singh
spokeswoman for harris if the trump
administration's war on mass has now
become a war on safety shields
that tells you everything you need to
know about why their coveted response is
a failure
okay well if indeed they are sitting 12
feet apart i am not sure that the
plexiglas barriers which
extend only like just above their heads
i'm not sure that that provides the kind
of protection you need because
presumably
if what you're deeply worried about is
the aerosolization of particles for
example
particles from your mouth do not travel
12 feet unless
unless you were to like sneeze and just
projectile
then really what you're worried about is
aerosolization if you're worried about
aerosolization then presumably they need
to both perform this debate
like john travolta and the boy from the
bubble will actually get some plastic
bubbles they can sit in them like a
hamster
ball and uh and that's how they can do
the debate
chris wallace the fox news anchor who
moderated the first presidential debate
said last week trump was not tested by
the cleveland clinic before taking the
stage
organizers relied on an honor system for
the vice presidential debate the
commission said harrison pence will be
coveted prior
to the debate unclear which entity will
oversee that testing susan page
the washington bureau chief of usa today
will not announce or question topics
ahead of time and paige is expected to
be seated 12 feet 3 inches
from both of the candidates okay so what
are we likely to see tonight the media
have already decided preemptively that
harris has won the debate
they've already decided that she because
she's a woman here her roar she has won
the debate the new york times reports
she's a barrier breaking hero
now here is my prediction for the debate
tonight i don't think that harris is
going to do well i don't think she's
good at debate
i think harris had one moment in a
debate and she literally could not back
it up
it turns out that her strategy typically
is to
make some sort of wild unverified
allegation the media cheer because they
think
that maybe she has something to verify
it and then it turns out she's got
nothing she did this with brett
kavanaugh
she suggested that he had been meeting
with the kasowitz law firm
trump's law firm to somehow do something
bad she never really specified what
and then she sort of dropped that line
of inquiry she went out there she sort
of implied
maybe that brett kavanaugh was a rapist
maybe just a little rapey
and then it turns out she had nothing to
back it up and of course you'll recall
that in her first debate
with joe biden she dropped an allegation
on him that she then backed off of
immediately
kamala harris is a very bad politician
and i expect that mike pence will
actually have the opportunity i'm
looking forward to the debate tonight
as opposed to some of the presidential
debates which i thought and i've been
saying for years
we're going to be chewbacca versus the
swedish chef we wouldn't get to any
content
we certainly wouldn't get any
clarification of how the candidates
actually
thought about issues i think that you
will get some clarification tonight and
i think pence is going to do a good job
you did a good job
last time against tim kaine we'll get
into more of this in a second and we'll
get into the harris agenda because
remember
the chances that kamala harris becomes
president are very very high if joe
biden becomes president
joe biden is 78 years old he's obviously
doddering he's obviously on his last
legs
the chances he's going to leave office
at the age of 86
are pretty low right if he wins you
think he's running for reelection at 82
and maybe he is but if he is diminished
if the different if the if the
the diminishment between if the delta
between 2000
and and 16 and 2020 for joe biden is the
same as the delta the
same as the change between 2020 and 2024
he's not going to be able to speak by
the time we hit 2024. we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that these
days you might want to protect yourself
you're seeing record gun sales these
days there's a reason for that people
are fearful about their freedoms they're
fearful about the future of the country
they're fearful about their safety
in many of america's biggest cities and
even in the suburbs because you never
know where the next riot is going to
break out and whether somebody's going
to try to burn down your business
you know who knows this the folks over
at bravo company manufacturing bravo
company was started in the garage of a
veteran
of the us marine corps in heartland
wisconsin the people at bravo company
manufacturing support the right of
responsible
private individuals to have the access
and ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement as a means of
defending ourselves our loved ones our
communities
and our freedoms should a threatening
situation ever arise bravo company
manufacturing this is not a sporting
arms company
they understand that primarily guns are
not really for hunting for target
shooting or for fun
that primarily they need to operate in
emergency situations where your life is
under actual threat
guns are life-saving equipment and bcm
knows this they assume that when a rifle
leaves their shop
it will be used in a life or death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas
quality is the utmost value to them
every component of a bcm rifle is hand
assembled and tested by americans
in heartland wisconsin to a life-saving
standard to learn more
about bravo company manufacturing head
on over to bravocompanymfg.com where you
can discover more about their products
special offers and upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing
find out even more about bcm and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa okay so
let's just flash back to kamala harris's
performance thus far and what you will
get with a president kamala harris
the only question with kamala harris
who's an extraordinarily opportunistic
politician
and she is somebody who will say
literally anything in order to get ahead
in her career anything the only question
is whether if she were president she
would be pragmatic
like bill clinton meaning that if she
felt the wind was blowing in favor of
moderation she would pursue that win
or whether as president she would feel
liberated from her shackles
and she could finally do the ideological
things she has always wanted to do
and it's really unclear with kamalaris
because she's taken every position it is
possible to take like all of them
every single position she also happens
to be deeply dishonest
and she would be a should be a deeply
dishonest president in a different way
than the media say trump is dishonest
the media will say i look at trump he's
lying again he's saying something that's
untrue again
donald trump speaks he's bilingual he
speaks english
but his his first language is hyperbole
right donald trump is
he he speaks hyperbole and so what the
media like to do is they take his
hyperbolic statements and then they
treat them
as though they are non-hyperbolic this
is something that apparently has become
very common in the media i've noticed it
the last few days
where i'll tweet an obvious joke and
then the media will treat it as though
i'm not saying a joke at all
i'll say something that is absolutely
100 a joke it is clear to anyone
who has a sentient part of their brain
that it is a joke and then members of
the media are like
he's probably not joking let's take it
seriously trump gets that treatment
all the time so they say he is dishonest
because he's hyperbolic
and it is also true that trump says
things that sometimes are just blatantly
not true
kamala harris is much more subtle she
makes claims
that are kind of true and kind of not
but she has no real substantiation and
then she waits for people to draw
inferences from them so she's a clever
liar
right she's not an obvious liar she's a
clever liar so
how would you like to have kamala harris
as your president because again remember
i said this the day she was nominated by
nominating kamala harris joe biden was
making himself secondary to the campaign
and if the trump campaign
had not been so focused in on whatever
it is trump wanted to do that day they
would have focused in on kamala harris
who is a deeply unlikable radical
who was so bad at her job that she
dropped out of the democratic primaries
before they even hit california because
she knew she was going to get skunked in
her home state
so as president kamal harris would be
dishonest like clintonian dishonest
presumption issue would be radical
because she has been radical in her
actual voting record
and she would be deeply vicious because
she has insulted huge swaths of
americans
as racist for not supporting her for not
supporting joe biden
she is like barack obama without any of
the charm basically
so if you liked the obama administration
particularly what it did to america you
would love a harris administration
and conversely if you didn't like barack
obama's administration
if you thought that barack obama was
radical enough for you and divisive
enough for you
then get ready because kamala harris
will double down on that to the nth
degree she's a more obvious politician
she's less subtle she does not use a
stiletto she uses a machete
okay so here let's just let's walk down
memory lane with kamala harris in
preparation for the debate tonight so
you'll remember this was the moment when
we
all learned that kamala harris was
supposedly a great debater this is where
kamala harris called her running mate a
racist essentially
it's personal and it was actually very
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california who was part of the second
class
to integrate her public schools and she
was bussed
to school every day and that little girl
was me
so much emotion in her voice and then
her campaign had a t-shirt up
on her campaign website within moments i
said by the way i said this at the time
that he was being unfairly maligned here
that opposing federal forced busing was
not in fact the wrong policy in the
1970s nor is it wrong policy today and
kamala harris would never
in fact stand in favor of federally
forced bussing but she attacked joe
biden
as a racist and then of course she
backed off of it you'll remember that
kamala harris suggested that joe biden
was in fact a sexual abuser and then she
backed off of this as well right this
kind of disappeared into the ether
when when there were accusers who came
out and suggested that joe biden had
touched them inappropriately
or against their consent she said i
believe the accusers in fact
after this she even went on to say maybe
joe biden should drop out of the race
here was kamala harris way back when
i believe them and i i respect
them being able to tell their story and
having the courage to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself
now she was asked about this right she
has been asked about this
and her answer was i'm focusing on trump
right now and this is the answer of
every single democrat
don't let that be the answer they should
have to answer basic
questions about whether they believe
whether she believes that her running
mate
is a racist or a rapist right she ought
to have to answer
those particular questions since she
threw out there those implications
she'd overly call him a racist all she
did was suggest that he would have
stopped little girls like her meaning
a black little girl from going to an
integrated public school that's what she
suggested on an open debate stage and
then backed off of it
she suggested that she believed the
accusers of joe biden and then she
backed off of it
she's deeply dishonest and pence should
press on this tonight
she's deeply dishonest on the issues you
have no idea where she stands
originally in the beginning of the
campaign she tried to hijack bernie
sanders
medicare for all shtick and then she ran
directly away from the medicare for all
shtick
in fact she told axios on hbo quote i
have to tell you honestly i knew it i
said to my team we need to do a better
plan this is not good enough
i said to my team i know we're going to
take a political hit for it i knew that
i knew we were
i knew i'd be called a flip-flopper for
that well if you knew you were going to
be called a flip-flopper for that then
why did you embrace medicare for all in
the first place and the answer is
because she's
such a political animal and she she is
just
a chameleonic politician with tendencies
toward the radical left
harris was asked specifically for
example about the price tag of the green
new deal so she was a senate co-sponsor
of the green new deal now the green new
deal
would cost according to aoc's plan some
trillion dollars 93 trillion dollars
okay which is crazy she was asked about
the price tag of what the green news
dealer cost and she just
elided the question completely three
trillion dollars a year for medicare for
all by some studies i don't
depending on which portions of the green
new deal you picked to do first that's
money
that you know what the republicans are
going to say tax and spend liberals pie
in the sky
one of the things that i admire and
respect is the measurement
that is captured in three letters roi
what's the return on the investment
people in the private sector understand
this really well it's not about a cost
it's about an investment
and then the question should be is it
worth
the cost in terms of the investment
potential are we going to get back more
than we put in
okay so this is the line that biden has
been using as well and bernie sanders
which is it doesn't matter how much
money you spend on the green new deal
ever because
there will be green jobs at the end of
it just like there were shovel ready
jobs at the end of barack obama's
stimulus that never materialized
just like the green jobs are van jones
produced zero green new jobs
while he was on staff at the obama
administration
kamala harris was asked about whether
she would be in favor of packing the
supreme court she refused to answer that
question as well
so where the hell does this lady stand
on anything you don't know all you know
is her voting record which is radically
leftist
and you know her personality which is
deeply dishonest and this lady
will probably be president of the united
states if joe biden is elected here she
was
failing to explain where she stands on
expanding the supreme court
if judge barrett is confirmed and
the democrats have control of the senate
next year and the white house and the
house representatives
should the supreme court be expanded
uh you know what let's i think that
first of all joe's been very clear
that um he is going to to
pay attention to the fact and i'm with
him on this one thousand percent
pay attention to the fact that right now
lawrence people are
voting
what is that what the f is that right
now people are voting so she won't
answer whether she should pack in the
court
she won't answer green new deal
questions on cost show and answer
medicare for all
she will not answer any serious policy
question at all
same thing with joe biden they're all
just gonna point at trump and the media
will let them get away with it and so if
joe biden wins here's who will be
emboldened the radical left who have
never had to answer a simple question
the media who have dishonestly covered
for the radical left
and members as we will see of the
so-called deep state meaning
members of the regulatory bodies of the
american executive branch
who acted in terrible fashion as it
turns out in 2016
and who will be put back in positions of
power if joe biden and kamal harris
were to gain the presidency meanwhile
joe biden is providing that facade for
democrats right the facade is that he is
moderate old joe slow old joe so he gave
another one of these generic speeches
yesterday
in gettysburg said gettysburg he decried
extremist
groups again right now this is this is
the shtick
for for joe biden is that when he says
extremist groups what he really means
is like people who don't like him i
don't mean
like it's one thing if he wants to
condemn white supremacists we all
condemn white supremacists okay let's
just be straight about this
statistically speaking white
supremacists
are a dangerous very very very small
subsection
of the american body politic they are
extremely dangerous when it comes to
individual attacks on synagogues for
example when it comes to mass movements
burning down cities it's not white
supremacist who are doing that it is
antifa and it is black lives matter
joe biden is first to the he's first to
the barricades when he's talking about
so-called
right-wing militias by which apparently
he means people like kyle rittenhouse
who is
apparently going to kenosha in order to
protect private property before he got
basically
cut off from his crowd and ended up
defending himself in the middle of a
riot by all available evidence
so joe biden is always willing to
condemn people who he thinks are not on
his side
see the the real test for joe biden
should have been months ago
whether he was willing to have a sister
soldier moment as it was called when
bill clinton condemned sister soldier
who was sort of an anonymous
and she's anonymous black lady who was
speaking about violence against the cops
and he condemned it and it was
considered like his big
moment to stand up against the hard left
joe biden has never had to do that
instead he just goes out there and says
generic things about how violence is bad
and this is supposed to be enough of a
pasteboard that you feel good about
electing him
you're not supposed to look behind that
curtain because behind that curtain
joe biden is not the wizard of oz he's
kamala harris with joe biden's face
and kamala harris has many faces as it
turns out some of them are radical
some of them are simply politically
expedient we'll get to joe biden
and his potemkin village campaign in
just one second first
let's talk about upgrading the look and
feel of your home
so if you look around your house one of
the things that you may notice now that
i'm saying it
is that your window covering stuck i'm
sorry to tell you they do i didn't mean
the first
to be the first to tell you this but you
really need to upgrade those window
coverings you got the blinds from the
wire that are hanging
you've got you know the old style
curtains that are just ridden with dust
and they're filthy
what you need are new window coverings
what's the best way to do this head on
over to blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters
from home with easy online ordering and
free shipping
the experts at blinds.com understand
that window treatments are one of the
household items you just don't think
about but they can make a huge impact on
the look and feel of your home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what's on your
windows you can change the way light
comes into your home you can create a
totally different feel
go to blinds.com just take a look at all
the options faux wood blinds cellular
own cellular and roller shades
even outdoor shades blinds.com has
helped millions of homeowners through
the process plus
they guarantee the perfect fit whether
you're do it yourself or have the
measure and install
everything for you go right now see how
much you can save at blinds.com
and when you check out online don't
forget to tell them you heard about
blinds.com from the ben shapiro show
that helps us it helps them as well
rules and restrictions may apply go
check out blinds.com
right now again blinds.com and upgrade
the look and feel of your home okay in
just a second
we're gonna get to joe biden and his
unifying message which apparently is
i'm not a bad person so vote for me that
that is joe biden's unifying message
i will condemn all sorts of extremism so
long as those extremists don't support
me
if they do support me then i don't
recognize them and i don't know who they
are and
sure they're standing right there but
they don't exist we'll get to that in
just one second
first let us remind you that tonight
is the vice presidential debate between
mike pence and kamala harris and we have
an all-access live we are forcing
forcing the daily wires matt walsh to
live react to the debate
join matt tonight at 8 45 pm eastern 5
45 p.m pacific at dailywire.com to live
chat with him on the live stream and in
the comments
if you're not part of daily wire already
join right now as an all-access member
and get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage live
at dailywire.com
apple tv or on the roku and join us on
all access live every night for live
stream discussions
you get not one but you leftist years
tumblers with your membership as well as
early sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products that's
tonight wednesday october 7th 8 45 pm
eastern
5 45 pm pacific join us get 20 off your
all-access membership with code debate
when you sign up today you are listening
to the largest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so biden has been you know basically
counting on the fact that you're going
to forget that he was vice president of
the united states when barack obama was
president but also
remember that he was vice president of
the united states when barack obama was
president by which i mean he doesn't
want to be tied to any real aspect of
the obama record he just wants you to
have this warm glowy feeling
about him the same way that many
americans have a warm glowy feeling
about barack obama because when it comes
to his actual record it sucks
so the other night he did an nbc news
town hall now it turns out by the way
that this nbc in just another indicator
of how crappy our media are
that nbc news town hall it turns out was
stacked with biden supporters
not kidding okay this is according to
the washington free beacon
the washington free beacon flagged that
there were two
voters who were supposedly undecided
voters at this
at this town hall event for nbc news
one's name was peter gonzalez the other
was is
they both questioned biden at the
october 5th town hall conducted by nbc
in miami
they were identified as undecided
florida voters gonzalez who said he was
an attorney in coral gables used his
slot to ask biden what he could say to
make people more comfortable voting for
him he said cuban-american and
venezuelan voters here in south florida
are being targeted with messages by the
trump campaign
claiming a vote for biden is vote for
the radical left and socialism and even
communism
what can you tell people in my family my
friends that would make them feel more
comfortable voting for biden and harris
gonzalez by the way did appear on msnbc
august 21st
as a republican for biden he was not an
undecided voter
he was a biden voter explaining his
position
that day gonzalez said if we get four
more years of trump good luck good luck
with the future attracting younger
voters
jano was introduced by lester holt as
someone who quote voted for hillary
clinton four years ago but has voted
republican in the past
he also appeared on msnbc this that same
day he praised biden's message as quote
what defines america is possibility
holt also introduced another attendee of
the town hall matteo gomez is a first
time voter
ms nbc featured gomez as recently as
september 30th
where he told a correspondent alison
barber that he would probably vote for
biden
so in other words they had three
undecided voters on that nbc news panel
all three of whom were open biden voters
which just shows you where our media are
anyway
joe biden was asked specifically about
about cuba
and about russia and joe biden was like
remember that time that my boss joe
my boss barack whatever his name was
remember that time he was really hard on
on cuba and putin and and i i like
oatmeal
here is joe biden i have taken on the
very people
that in fact we're worried about i've
taken on the castros of the world i've
taken on the putins of the world i've
taken on
all these dictators i haven't cozied up
to them i'm the guy that's been
straightforward with them
i'm the guy that let them know it stops
here
it stops with me it stops with me as
president
i am no more a socialist than uh or a
communist than
donald trump is well i won't say it
anyway
is that i mean that that's just a it's a
lie it's an over lie right when you
actually look at his policy
barack obama was making cozy with like
literally making physically cozy with
raul castro
in non-coveted style i mean like really
getting up in his grill
and they were best friends at a baseball
game in cuba
and they were holding hands it was real
weird it was it was barack obama and joe
biden who made room for vladimir putin
to take over crimea and syria
but don't worry you're not supposed to
remember that you're supposed to just
believe what joe biden is telling you
now because of after all he's the nice
old man
who's gonna tell you that he doesn't
like when people are mean to each other
even though he is one of the meanest
players in in partisan politics for for
the last
you know several decades here was joe
biden at gettysburg yesterday decrying
extremist groups he'll never mention
antifa here right antifa is an idea it's
not a movement
we have no need for armed militias
roaming america streets
and we should have no tolerance for
extremist white supremacy groups
menacing our communities
if you say we should trust america's law
enforcement authorities to do the job
as i do then let them do their job
god extremist groups acting as
vigilantes he's just such an
unbelievable liar he's such an
unbelievable liar
he hates the cops okay he says things
like the cops are nice people but also
they're systematically racist
the entire policing system is
systemically racist either he doesn't
know what the term systemically racist
means which is possible because he's an
idiot
or he knows exactly what it means and
he's just a liar about his affinity
for the police maybe the only effective
debate moment for trump was when he said
name a police group that supports you
and biden couldn't because of course he
doesn't have police supporting him
and when he talks about people menacing
american streets are you kidding me
right now
it's the white supremacists menacing the
streets of portland menacing the streets
of chicago
and la and new york literally two nights
ago
blm was breaking windows in downtown l.a
in portland
the idiot leftists are about to elect a
member of a self-declared member of
antifa
to the mayoralty but don't worry joe
biden is gonna
joe biden is definitely gonna be a
bulwark for moderation okay so just
remember remember again this is the
message of today's show
remember that when you elect joe biden
you're not just electing someone who
isn't trump you're electing joe biden
you're electing kamala harris these are
the people who are going to be in charge
of the country
and you know who else is going to be put
back in charge of the country all the
folks like john brennan
so according to fox news the director of
national intelligence john ratcliffe on
tuesday declassified documents that
revealed former cia director john
brennan
briefed former president obama on
hillary clinton's purported plan
to tie then-candidate donald trump to
russia as quote a means of distracting
the public
from her use of a private email server
ahead of the 2016 presidential election
ratcliffe declassified brennan's
handwritten notes which were taken after
he briefed obama on the intelligence the
cia received
and a cia memo which revealed that
officials referred the matter to the fbi
for potential investigative action
the office of the dni transmitted the
first declassified
documents to the house and senate
intelligence committees on tuesday
afternoon
a source familiar with the documents
explained brennan's handwritten notes
were taken after briefing obama on the
matter
brennan's notes said quote we're getting
additional insight into russian
activities from
redacted site summarizing material
alleged approval by hillary clinton a
proposal from one of her foreign policy
advisors to vilify donald trump by
stirring up a scandal
claiming interference by the russian
security service
the notes state on july 28th in the
margin brennan writes potus
that section of the notes is redacted
any evidence of collaboration between
trump campaign and russia the notes read
the remainder of the notes are redacted
except in the margins which read jc
dennis and susan
presumably this would refer to james
comey susan would be susan rice and
dennis would be dennis mcdonough obama's
chief of staff
so the cia memo i mean that is
really ugly stuff i mean what that looks
like
what it looks like is that the obama cam
the obama team was being informed in
real time by john brennan
of laundered hillary clinton dirt on
donald trump with regard to russia by
the way they knew was false because
christopher steele was enacting was
interacting
with as it turns out a person who's
suspected of being a russian agent for
all of his bad intel and it was being
laundered
through the amer through america's
intelligence services i mean this is
like
devastating stuff my supposition
throughout russiagate
was that it was founded in good faith
and that people then took it too far
because i always attribute to stupidity
as much as i can without attributing it
to malice
when you have john brennan writing in
his handwritten notes that we know
hillary clinton
is attempting to stir up crap and then
he's feeding it directly so obama knew
about it also
and then the intelligence services
investigated it anyway and decided to
falsify
fisa warrants and or fisa warrants in
order to go after people like carter
pages it starts to look a lot
like the worst of the theories the worst
of the
sort of dark conspiratorial theories
about the
about america's intelligence services
radcliffe said to be clear this is not
russian disinformation it has not been
assessed as such by the intelligence
community
a source familiar with the documents
told fox news the allegation was not
disinformation the source said this is
not russian disinformation
even brennan knew or who wouldn't be
briefing the president of the united
states on it
there's a high threshold to orally brief
the president of the united states
he clearly felt this met the threshold
another source familiar with the
documents told fox news this information
has been sought by hundreds of
congressional requests for legitimate
oversight purposes
and was withheld for political spite and
the belief they would never
be caught so this is really disturbing
stuff
the clinton campaign and dnc through the
law firm perkins coy
hired fusion gps and ex-intelligence
officer rich
british intelligence officer christopher
steele to author and compile information
in that trump dossier the anti-trump
dossier
and of course that was used as the basis
for that fisa warrant against carter
page
and now it looks like it looks like
brennan was informing
barack obama the entire time not only
that this investigation was underway
but also that they knew that there was a
a proposal
from hillary clinton to vilify trump by
stirring up the scandal
if they were complicit in that that is
that that is insane
that is insane paul sperry the former dc
bureau chief for investors business
daily
who's been on top of this stuff he says
when all documents are finally
declassified
and all the redactions are removed from
reports the nation will see that the fbi
and cia not only knew
the russian collusion allegations
against trump were a political dirty
trick but that they were in on the trick
in other words that brennan and company
fully knew that this was a trick
and they decided to activate america's
intelligence services on behalf of
hillary clinton which is just
i mean that is a breathtaking scandal if
that turns out to be true so yesterday
donald trump released a tweet he said i
have fully authorized the total
declassification of any and all
documents pertaining to the single
greatest political crime in american
history the russia hoax likewise
likewise the hillary clinton email
scandal no redactions
so could that redirect all of this stuff
could that change the nature of the race
theoretically if it turns out that
that the dni has now declassified
and has now declassified information
suggesting that the entire intelligence
apparatus knew that this was a hillary
dirty trick and decided to take part in
the dirty trick
that is astonishing stuff so we will see
if that
is uh we will see if that is backed up
in the coming days because if so
that's not only is that bad those are
the people who will be back in power
right those are the people
who you will put back back in power the
john brennans of the world
to again militarize america's
intelligence services which is
deeply disturbing and uh and troubling
stuff okay meanwhile
the media prefer to focus in on
president trump and as usual president
trump
tries to take center stage as i've said
i said this yesterday
i said that if trump loses by double
digits to this daughtering old fool
and his radical comrade vice
presidential candidate
then that is if you lose by if you lose
a little bit i understand that's just
you have overwhelming forces arrayed
against you right if there are
overwhelming forces that are arrayed
against trump in the media
in the democratic party in hollywood and
those are very difficult forces for
anybody to overcome john mccain
mitt romney doesn't matter anybody to
overcome if you're a republican
particularly
okay but if he loses by double digits to
joe biden
as the incumbent president then at a
certain point you're gonna have to say
this is donald trump
that was not meant to be like a
concession of the election
what that is meant to do is convince
trump there's still a month left and he
needs to change
tax right now he needs to change tax
because here's the reality if you
believe that donald trump is the only
person who can win
and if donald trump is not the blame for
losing what you're really suggesting is
no republican will ever be president
ever again now maybe that's true
and maybe that's not but that seems like
a rather pessimistic message
i don't believe that i don't think
that's true i think that trump can win
this election i think a republican
who plays this right can win the
election in spite of all of those
various allied forces and i mean
none of that is to downplay the power of
those forces but if you want trump to
win he needs to do a better job
obviously
and what that means is not making the
kinds of mistakes that he made yesterday
okay the fact is that putting back in
power the obama team would be disastrous
barack obama was a deeply divisive
president i think he was transforming
i think that he fundamentally
transformed america i think he did
succeed in his quest
and i don't think it's through obamacare
i don't even think it's through daca
i think he fundamentally transformed
america by taking a country that was
ready for racial reconciliation
and then tearing it apart for his own
political benefit by creating an
intersectional coalition
that he believed would radically change
the nature of how american politics was
performed
in which we would pit the races against
once and one another
again on behalf of barack obama and then
we would hope that the
the new majority minority america in
terms of voting
doesn't really exist yeah right i mean
the fact is the vast majority of the
voting base is still white but
basically white liberal allies combined
with the intersectional coalition that
they would be the new majority in
american politics and you could simply
ignore
the the wants and desires of the rest of
america it was all about base turnout
from now on
barack obama fundamentally shifted the
nature of american politics and then
donald trump was sort of a reaction to
that
well you know as we move toward the
election you need to be reminded that
barack obama's team would be back in
power
michelle obama who continues to be
portrayed by the media as a
non-political figure she's deeply
political
and she was always deeply radical i mean
it's easier to forget
but before she became the second coming
of oprah michelle obama was the lady
who said in 2008 that she had only been
proud of her country
one time and that was when they
nominated her husband for president
well now michelle obama's out there
saying that trump is a racist divisive
failure
and that he has created he's so division
and
the obama administration sowed an awful
lot of division an awful lot of division
right now the president and his allies
are trying to tap
into that frustration and distract
from his breathtaking failures by giving
folks
someone to blame other than them so what
the president is doing is
once again patently false
it's morally wrong and yes
it is racist okay again
putting these people back in power
saying that everything is racist
that's going to be a big mistake and
this is why it's so important that trump
shift
that he shifts strategy and then he
swivel this boat he's got to turn the
boat if the boat doesn't turn
then those people going to be back in
power the john brennans the michelle
obamas the barack obamas the joe bidens
the kamala harris's
your mainstream media who have been
who have been twisting the narrative
every minute of
every day they will be weaponized to a
degree you have never seen before
they really will they're trying it on
social media right now they are trying
to leverage the power of the media in
order to pressure social media to shut
down conservative messages
that that power is out there every
single day they're angry
that shows like this one are successful
they're pissed off that anybody on the
right danes to have a media outlet that
doesn't repeat the narratives of the new
york times
they're going to leverage every aspect
of that power should trump lose
and this is why trump needs to get it
together
he does this is encouragement for trump
there's not a critique this
encouragement
dude turn it around and what you can't
do is what trump did yesterday so
yesterday
trump made a bizarre move he tweeted out
that he was going to end negotiations
over additional covet 19 stimulus
okay so he first tweeted out that
he was basically done which is really
dumb okay this was 2 48 p.m this is 2 48
p.m
eastern time yesterday he said that he
had told his administration's
negotiators to end the coronavirus
stimulus talks with democrats until
after the
november third elections he said i've
instructed my representatives to stop
negotiating until after the election
when immediately after i win
we will pass a major stimulus bill that
focuses on hard-working americans
and small business he added that he had
asked senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell to focus full-time on
confirming
amy coney barrett in the senate which of
course is going to happen anyway
this is political malpractice it is so
bad okay the reason it is so bad
is because the fact is that nancy pelosi
had owned the failure here
nancy pelosi has been holding up a
relief package
for months at this point for no reason
whatsoever
the republicans have proposed a clean
relief package in which american
families got 1200 bucks
republicans proposed spending 1.4
trillion dollars that is a lot of money
1.4 trillion dollars in another relief
package and democrats turned it down
because they wanted the states bailed
out they wanted localities bailed out
they wanted andrew cuomo's bills paid in
new york
and republicans said no we need a relief
package we don't need an android cuomo
bailout package that's not the same
thing
and nancy pelosi had basically walked
away from the table the failure of the
relief package could have been one of
trump's talking points over the past
couple months you forgot about it
because
trump was busy tweeting about whatever
but the fact is that that should have
been a chief point right
is that the democrats want to shut down
the economy and then not provide you the
relief you need they want to shut it
they want to lock down
everything not allow you to go to work
and then block any relief bill in the
house
and that's egregious that should have
been the narrative instead trump
yesterday tweets out that he's going to
end the relief negotiations
before they even hit the election like
until the election
it's just a complete blunder it's
complete unforced error obviously
well about a few hours later four hours
later trump reversed himself
and then he tweeted out the house and
senate should immediately approve 25
billion for airline
payroll support 135 billion for paycheck
protection program for small business
both of these will be fully paid for
with unused funds from the cares act
have this money i will sign now right so
he realized about four hours later he'd
made a boo-boo
and that unilaterally declaring that you
were not going to sign a relief package
or negotiate for one right now is a bad
move
four weeks before an election right
that's the stock market by the way
plummeted like 300 points as soon as
trump tweeted that
because people were automatically
assuming that congress was not gonna
they couldn't no one could be foolish
enough to stop a relief package
permanently here
right so trump made an unforced error
there it was big boo-boo how big of a
was it susan collins who's running a
rough reelection campaign in maine she
said this is a huge mistake
she said waiting until after the
election to reach an agreement on the
next covenant 19 relief package is a
huge mistake
i've already been in touch with the
secretary of the treasury one of the
chief negotiators with several of my
senate colleagues
when the pandemic began republicans and
democrats in congress worked together
successfully to take quick
sweeping action allocating nearly 3
trillion bucks since march
to respond to the crisis passing the
bipartisan paycheck protection program i
co-authored that has provided
more than two billion dollars to 28 000
main small businesses helping to sustain
228 000 25 250 000 rather main jobs
that's the same approach we need to take
now to continue to provide support for
the health and safety of all americans
mitch mcconnell immediately came out he
said no no we're still negotiating here
nancy pelosi for her part she was so
excited i mean that grin that is
normally
stuck on her face simply because of uh
simply because of the botox
now it's stuck on there because she was
actually happy
she apparently told democratic lawmakers
that she thought that it was because
trump was high on steroids
according to two sources on a dnc phone
call she said trump's thinking might be
affected by steroids he's taken to treat
his coronavirus
infection pelosi said in a statement
complete clearly the white house is in
complete disarray
walking away from kova talks
demonstrates that trump is unwilling to
crush the virus as is required by the
heroes act
mcconnell said he stood by the
president's position he said i think his
view is that they were not going to be
able to produce a result we needed to
concentrate on what's achievable
it's because mcconnell doesn't want to
draw too much daylight but you know
trump got it right later in the
afternoon then he tweeted in favor of
covet relief
it was a brief boo-boo and now look for
the media to
play that brief boo-boo into a giant
overarching policy change with regards
to a relief package right it's an
unforced error by trump and the media
will undoubtedly double down and turn it
into a major issue
day in and day out from here until the
election even though it's very very
clear that nancy pelosi is the person
who's been holding up the relief package
now speaking of covid
speaking of covet worth noting that the
nypd last night
under the tutelage of bill de blasio
they broke up a sukkot celebration
in new york so as you know i am not a
fan
of the fact that so many orthodox jews
have been out in the streets getting
together there's been a
i care about all american life i care
about orthodox jewish life as well
i have many friends in the orthodox
jewish community since i'm a member of
the orthodox jewish community
people who are gathering together in
large crowds and shows it's a mistake
that does not mean that it is not wildly
hypocritical for andrew cuomo and bill
de blasio to simply target the jews
in new york it's pretty amazing actually
okay so here was video last night of the
nypd
trying to break up a sukkot celebration
they're a bunch of people out in the
streets celebrating the festival of
booths again
don't do this guys um but the nypd
breaks this up
they should have brought their black
lives matter signs then the nypd would
have been forced to back off by bill de
blasio clearly
[Applause]
in the streets and the nypd is actually
pushing them together like i feel like
this is a bad strategy
they're pushing them closer together the
celebration in the middle of the street
now again i actually don't have a
problem with breaking up large-scale
gatherings without masks at this point
my question is why didn't they do this
for months when it was black lives
matter protest
was it okay when there was a giant crowd
painting black lives matter on fifth
avenue
so bill de blasio and andrew cuomo it's
the selectivity that's really the
problem
jimmy vilkind who is a wall street
journal reporter
covering new york politics and
government he uh he put out a statement
uh this is a statement from various
different members of the
of the brooklyn political establishment
new york senator felder eichenstein
jaeger and hayem deutsch
they said they were appalled by governor
cuomo's words and actions because
governor cuomo came out and said
basically the orthodox jews have to be
stopped he said we are appalled by
governor
cuomo's words and actions today he has
chosen to pursue a scientifically and
constitutionally questionable shutdown
of our communities
his administration's utter lack of
coordination and communication with
local officials
has been an ongoing issue since the
start of the pandemic and particularly
recently
as we face this uptick but we are
representatives of the hot spot
neighborhoods we have been disconcluded
from conversations with the governor
they say what occurred today can only be
described as a duplicitous bait and
switch
the governor informed jewish community
leaders in a conference call synagogues
and quote unquote red zones would be
permitted to operate at 50 percent
he requested a community cooperation and
then outrageously he announced a
draconian return to restrictions that
would shudder thousands of new york
businesses
limit houses of worship to a maximum
capacity of 10 no matter the capacity of
the building
even worse his rhetoric has been
irresponsible and pejorative
particularly to a community of holocaust
survivors and their descendants for whom
his language was reminiscent of past
verbal attacks on jewish communities
okay so again it is not wrong to to
break up
large-scale gatherings to prevent covet
it is definitely wrong to target jews
while you are perfectly willing to blame
systemic american racism for upticks in
covet
it is demonstrative of the
intersectional coalition's viewpoint on
politics than when there's a significant
uptick
in a black community and then video
emerges from that community of people
holding giant parties in indoor spaces i
remember early on in the pandemic
there was a there's a video that came
out of chicago of a giant thousand
person house party in chicago
everyone there was was a person of color
this was not covered by the media
at all but when jews gather in a
synagogue in large numbers that of
course is a big story when christians
gather in a church
that of course is a large story the
double standard is absolutely telling
i have a single standard which is be
responsible and don't spread covet if
you can avoid it
the the members of the democratic party
however have a deep and abiding
double standard the double standard is
that you should be afraid of kovid
if you are an orthodox jew but
apparently if you're protesting for
black lives matter you should not
andrew cuomo yesterday he came out and
he said that when trump says don't be
afraid of quote you should be afraid of
kobe they can kill you
but apparently not if you're protesting
for the right things here was andrew
cuomo yesterday
from a public service point of view 210
000 people died
more people die
in this country than uh
countries around the world that were
doing much
uh worse than we were from a public
service point of view
don't be afraid of covert no be afraid
of
covid it can kill you don't be
cavalier don't be cavalier unless of
course you are protesting for the right
reasons
again i agree don't be cavalier uh and
but but
two things one democrats are
simultaneously promoting panic
about the virus which is not justified
concern about the virus is justified
precautions about the virus those are
justified panic about the virus is not
justified and simultaneously
if you protest for the right reasons
then we should just pretend that racism
is a quote unquote public health problem
and that's totally okay
it's the double standard that's driving
many americans up a wall okay we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content and of
course
tune in to daily wear tonight to watch
matt walsh be forced to suffer
through the kamala harris mike pence
debate we'll be back here to recap all
of it tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick schien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
liberals don't get why masks are
political because they don't understand
politics
facebook censors president trump for
encouraging people and michelle obama
calls us all racists again
check it out on the michael knowles show
you